hi exploded force here I'm here with
Glamour UK and today I'm talking about
my new book and all things you see and
vlogging so I started back in 2009 which
is really early days for YouTube and at
the time I really didn't have a clue
what it was gonna be like at all nothing
really existed in the same way than it
does now on YouTube it was all kind of
for a bit of fun really and I just
started talking about products that I
love and how I apply my maker for things
like that just things that I was
passionate about and so it really hasn't
changed that much in terms of the
content like the type of content where
it comes from because I still talk about
what I love but I think the production
has improved it a little bit over time
as I've learnt a bit more about cameras
and editing and stuff and and yeah I
think the contents got a bit broader as
well so do some interior stuff now a bit
more fashion than I used to excited to
do all beauty and quite a lot of life
slightly stuff as well
how to edit there's a lot of things I
had to teach myself early days but I
think it's all been really fun kind of
learning it and also because everything
was so different when I started it's
almost been a really nice experience
being part of that development into an
industry because it started off with
people just sitting in their bedroom
talking to a camera now it's turned into
a whole kind of separate arm of
traditional media so it's been really
nice being part of that so I feel like I
wouldn't change too much definitely the
freedom to be able to make your own kind
of timings and being able to work in
your pajamas it's also amazing when
you're at home the worst thing is
definitely not knowing when to stop
never being able to switch off so I'm
like always on my email always on
Instagram always on Twitter which I feel
like everybody is nowadays but I don't
have that like clock off time like yes
I'm leaving the office outlet Friday
feet Friday feeling sorry when I go home
and like I don't get that which is
pretty sad
and never have a typical day I could do
a typical week more likely because it
usually involves a lot of either travel
or moving around I'm not based in London
so you have to come down to London for a
couple of days a week usually about
three days a week for meetings or shoots
it depends on what projects I'm working
on at the time so I've also just
finished writing my book which took up a
lot of my time towards the beginning of
the year but now I see I'm not doing
that so it really depends what I'm doing
that week and that's what I love about
it because it's so spontaneous and a lot
of the projects come up fairly
last-minute as well so it's kind of like
you know can you go to America next week
can you go to Costa Rica look after
things like that it's very much a little
bit spontaneous and fun but sometimes a
bit unnerving like I like to be
organized but it kind of doesn't always
happen how my schedule is all planned
out
when I was little I think I wanted to be
a lawyer because I quite liked arguing
and I thought that would be great to be
also arguing people for a living I don't
think I quite understood it probably
what a lawyer was at that point and then
I spent quite a lot of my kind of late
teens and early twenties before I
started YouTube working in events so I
think that's probably what I would have
ended up doing more realistically
yeah so the new book is what I like to
call slightly more grown-up older sister
on my first book so it still got a lot
of the beauty and fashion content that
people will expect from me in there but
it's got a bit more of a kind of
entertaining at home interiors kind of
vibe to it as well there's a lot more
content I think that people won't
necessarily expect which I'm really
excited to see how that goes down it's
been a little bit more hard work than
the first one because I think with the
first book I kind of knew exactly what I
wanted to write and it was I've had all
of my ideas so quickly and it will kind
of came together so easily from my
content I already make online whereas
this one's a little bit different so I
feel like I'm a bit more proud of it
because it's been harder work to
actually put it together and write it
but yeah I'm really excited people to
see it
yeah I do get stopped by subscribers all
the time actually and I sometimes get
more excited than they do because I
think a lot of the time people forget
when you're doing usually if you
actually on your own in the room a lot
of the time and especially when you're
actually filming content and making
content so it's actually really nice to
meet the people that watch and comment
and you know you kind of build up that
relationship online but a lot of the
time don't get Smeaton in real life so
yeah that's one of the best bits
I think definitely a misconception in
terms of fame because I don't think it
is like traditional Fame at all it's a
lot more niche and a lot more personal
the connection you make with your
subscribers is a lot more personal it is
hard to work than it looks but at the
same time it is also really great fun as
well I absolutely love my job and I
would never sit here and be like I work
so hard all that kind of stuff because I
love it I love every single day
but I would say if you are wanting to
get into YouTube or start your own blog
is be realistic be persistent because it
takes ages to build a following be
consistent and keep posting regular
content so that people know when to come
back and be yourself especially in video
format because people can tell if you're
kind of putting on a persona or being
somebody that you're not that's you know
an instant kind of giveaway and I think
people don't connect with you in the
same way because that's why people watch
you is for your personality
I wouldn't say it doesn't ever worry me
but it's not so much of an issue to me
because I don't live in the center of
town so there's not so many people kind
of around where I live I live in the
countryside I understand
the five-year question is one of the
hardest questions to ask because when I
first started this I had no idea it
would be here now where it is now but I
think for me you know there's so much
going on and there has been a lot going
on over the past 18 months in particular
that I've been focusing on that a lot
looking forward I mean I'd love to
expand a few things that I'm doing
already I'm actually expanding my
eyelash range Lila this summer and then
might be a further extension of
something coming along those lines soon
which I'm really excited about and also
my second books coming out so that's the
focus for the moment I feel like one day
I would love to have my own fashion
range that's definitely something I
would absolutely love to do I'm also in
the process and moment of kind of
revamping the look of all of my sites
and things so I think I'm gonna try and
try and make things that look a little
bit more premium as I've grown up on
YouTube as well so I feel like I've been
doing seven years now I've kind of
literally grown up myself on YouTube so
I think my content has gradually been
growing up so it's kind of just updating
everything for that as well so we'll see
who knows where YouTube's going to be in
another five years
I've done a few things on TV and I like
it and I would never rule it out it's
never been like the aim of the game it's
never been my end goal but if the right
project came up I would definitely be
interested in doing so TV stuff yeah you
know what I actually don't obsess about
Instagram nearly as much as everybody
else and I feel like I need to because
every time I talk to other bloggers
they're like oh my lay out all looks you
know my grid look looks perfect and I've
got a color scheme and this and that I
tend to look at Instagram more from the
like traditional way of looking at
Instagram in fact that you post you take
a picture in your post it's right away
there's a lot of people plan so far in
advance and I do that to a certain
extent but I'm definitely not obsessed
with it I'm more into kind of like
posting when it happens and keeping that
like live element there because I think
if you let contents it for too long
sometimes it goes a little bit of stale
maybe that's in my mind but I feel like
it's kind of past you know I mean
I think he would actually go well up on
the Instagram husband and say he's a
YouTube husband so when that video came
out he watched it laughed and was like
they should try and be a youtube husband
let's see my life so yes he definitely
is he's learnt so much about cameras and
how to film and how I like being in
films and things like that and he's
actually quite good at it now he was
terrible in the beginning used to like
cut my head off or cut my feet off every
single time he's actually pretty good
now so and I think he enjoys it more
than more than some people maybe I don't
really watching Game of Thrones maybe
but then I've usually got my phone on at
the same time I know that's terrible
I'm like triple screening most of the
time that and I guess Sunday's chilling
out with my family when I get the chance
to do that
I mean obviously bringing out this book
but bringing out the first book was
pretty amazing as well as never kind of
something I thought that I would do so
it was really amazing to actually go
through that whole process and take on
something as big as writing a book which
was quite daunting at the start so I
think for me like the first book launch
was probably like that moment where I
was like I can't actually beat this
believe this it's happening and it's
mine like when I held the hard copy for
the first time it's a pretty special
moment
you